et mieux valu ce bonjour vous êtes le
fondateur de l'application de transfert
d'argent il ya la caste qui généralement
fait des transferts entre le canada et
le mans 11e remercier d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
bonjour c'est bien je suis vraiment
content d'être là pour parler de la cage
ses aises
alors eh bien là le chili à une année à
peu près on vous a accueilli pour ou à
ce moment là vous nous annonciez le
lancement de l'application
c'était déjà annoncé mais ont parlé pour
la première fois sur scène
internationale au bout d'une année quel
bilan faites vous de toutes ces douze
derniers mois
on n'a parfois rien un branchement au
final et on est rendu à pratiquement
plus de 5000 clients
la communauté marocaine à mal les défis
pour connaître nos clients des livres
est de plus en plus d'argent alors notre
application vraiment une expansion façon
en volume et un nombre d'utilisateurs et
on a eu droit à beaucoup de défis en
plein de sens du temps pour satisfaire
donc les hommes surtout faire
l'application la plus magnifique
possible pour transférer l'argent le
moins cher possible rapidement et
surtout sans friction donc ça ça va mon
bilan
on a grandi comme comme si et compagnie
en termes d'apprentissage ou de
comportement des clients et leurs
besoins surtout là-bas à destination
j'imagine que pendant toute cette année
vous avez rencontré certaines
difficultés que ce soit lié au
fonctionnement du système d'ici au
canada ou au maroc
quels sont les principaux défis que vous
avez eu à affronter les principaux défis
je dirais sont plusieurs
le premier c'est servir le volume ce qui
était grandissante sur tout par rapport
aux besoins du cobp il savait que
dernièrement c'est ça qu'on veut ni a eu
beaucoup d'impact économique
nous on a vu par mes augmentation
substantielle des transferts d'argent et
surtout la manière de servir et qui en a
pas les destinataires qui a changé
radicalement plutôt du volume très tôt
le matin pour supporter les familles en
cas de chômage pour la santé pour payer
des soins aussi basiquement que ça et
donc ça c'est un grand défi et il était
vraiment sur le sur le terrain pour
aider nos clients pour envoyer l'argent
à leur famille leur donne ce matin
est-ce que vous avez mesuré l'impact de
la pandémie sur le volume des échanges
ce soir entre le maroc ou bien partout
dans le monde
est ce que parce qu'on y va parce que là
certains pays où l'apport des transferts
d'argent de la diaspora est très
important et ça ça participe aussi au
développement économique
est-ce que vous avez des chiffres sur sa
wii en fait dépendent en euros loin du
pays
il ya un volume annuel qui entre pour
nous entre deux entre 10 et 12 milliards
$ us
on ne conteste la pandémie nous notre
côté et volumes ont augmenté de 30 à 40%
certaines applications de transport
d'argent en fait un avantage ça n'a pas
de réel parce que sur place la crise
économique de faire de perdre leur
emploi elles mêmes ne pas les ossements
de santé fait que c'est un nom beaucoup
l'autre chose si c'est qu'elle l'a on
lui a rendu un transport à annuelle de
700 milliards de dollars dans le monde
les etats-unis ont représente d'après
clan pensants mais c'est quelque chose
qui bat grande salle les grands
financeurs de développement économique
dans les pays à destination en afrique
c'est la diaspora c'est pas la banque
mondiale ce n'est pas les la famille
c'est la diaspora avant d'aller voir
puisque vous parlez des états unis est
ce que ce marché vous intéresse est ce
que ça peut être intéressant pour vous
puisqu'il est il y là de l'extension
dans ce marché ouais totalement en fait
on a beaucoup d'appels de pied de la
communauté marocaine mais d'autres
segments de villa park a surtout afrique
de l'ouest et aux etats unis
on parle de la côte est on parle de la
région du michigan
on parle du texas et les états du sud
beaucoup de communautés si là-bas comme
des sénégalais des jeunes en afrique de
l'ouest
des tunisiens même des âges jeunes le
monde allait là bas donc on est en train
de déployer trouver les acras parce
qu'il faut bien entendu une licence
comme une sens de transfert d'argent et
on a beau n'est ce pas déjà levé début
2011 22
c'est quelque chose qui en sait quelque
chose qui verra si moi je suis un
internaute ou bien j'ai monté les
français du là et que je tombe sur une
application de transfert d'argent
qu'est-ce qui me garantit que jetons que
c'est une
c'est une application légale et que je
suis pas en train de participer à
quelque chose d'illégal et que je suis
pas en phase d' escroc qui vont
comprendre mon argent c'est quoi les
garanties quels conseils vous donnerez à
quelqu'un qui pose cette question
c'est exactement le défi quand il ya nos
clients les premiers pour savoir ce
qu'il nous fallait nous faire confiance
à sony de nouveau dans le voeu d'un
marché donc la première chose à vérifier
c'est est ce que cette entreprise a une
licence légale pour opel donc le fil fac
en anglais aucun n'a fait ici autant
plus si l on perde au québec il faut
avoir le sens de des autorités de
marchés financiers c'est très important
et après vieille ville leur site
internet et surtout parce que la société
existe vraiment rien qu'avec le château
incorporation canada même le registre du
québec permet de voir ce que cette
entreprise a une existence réelle et
après notamment fait beaucoup de nos
clients des bars en trans fait des
petits montants pour tester à ce que
l'application de malmö services
financiers réels et délibérément la
valeur qui promet c'est dans la salle
des conseils
il n'y a pas le feu vous n'êtes pas la
seule application ou la seule compagnie
qui offre ce service
surtout qu'il ya des grosses compagnies
qui existe depuis longtemps qu est ce
qui ferait que c'est quoi votre plus
value sans que vous nous servier le
discours de marketing habituel je ne
refuse pas mais que voudrait un peu
aller un peu au delà de ça oui
en fait la première raison serait le
coup c'est les recevant les grandes
compagnies de factures entre à 10 et 15%
du montant total avec les free cash et
qui sont le dos ça ça serait le premier
argument nous ne commence la deuxième
chose c'est notre service client et même
la plupart de nos activités sont faites
en production ce qui fait que l'emploi
ait créé là bas et on essaie de
favoriser l'économie en afrique
en faisant ça troisième chose
et tous là un ami en fait nos stocks
pendant dix ans par fiscaux aux
optimisations mais on est vraiment
service des économies des pays à
destination pour faire donner le plus de
valeur possible lors d'un transfert pour
payer l'éducation la santé le support
familial les pensions des anciens et
même investir dans son pays d'origine ce
qui fait que une vraie plus-value un
impact que quelqu'un un transfert vous
voulez y aller avec une grande campagne
anglaise ou autre qui va mettre c'est
qui va salir ses actionnaires
l'angleterre merci beaucoup admiré la
nuit je rappelle que vous êtes le
fondateur de l'application de transfert
d'argent il ya la cage qui
principalement à travers entre le canada
et les mains merci merci